a controversial lecture on nutrition
calls into question the health claims
for coconut oil a Harvard adjunct
professor who focuses on the role of
nutrition in disease called the oil pure
poison coconut oils superfood status
with challenge last year when the
American Heart Association recommended
limited use it warned of the oils
potential to raise bad cholesterol and
the risk of heart disease
Samantha Heller is a registered
dietician at NYU Langone health good
morning good morning all right
this Harvard professor said that coconut
oil is poison is it one of the worst
foods you can eat I was everyone
everyone here at CBS I gave her there
like coconut oil No
can I eat it it's not going to kill you
coconut oil is fine it's delicious you
can use it in all kinds of interesting
dishes a curry dish a Thai dish but it
is a saturated fat and saturated fat we
know raises the risk for cardiovascular
disease and internal information it's in
the same category as butter and lard so
use it occasionally in dishes that you
like and that's great but it has an
undeserved health halo you know you go
on the internet and it says it's curing
Alzheimer's disease and cancer and helps
you lose weight and we have no evidence
to substantiate those claims so how did
it become a superfood I think partly
because of those those claims that
people want something easy I asked
everyone here who said I love coconut
oil what did you hear someone heard it
speeded metabolism that it was healthier
than butter that it would help them lose
weight that it would help their skin and
hair topically it does but internally
not so much and I think we like quick
fixes we want a magic bullet we want
something fantastic and easy and super
miraculous and coconut oil just doesn't
fit that bill according to the evidence
that we have right now Marketing /
science is the idea that it's poison
though based on the idea that saturated
fat has this relationship to heart
disease and isn't and hasn't that been
changing quite a lot saturated fat is
really quite directly related to
increasing levels of bad cholesterol in
your blood it's all biochemistry and
very complicated and we eat food we
don't eat nutrients we don't just sit
and eat a plate of saturated fat so we
look at dietary patterns and the Western
diet the foods we normally eat in this
country hi we're
and processed meat and junk food a lot
of cheese and a lot of butter and a lot
of you know fried foods that increases a
risk for a lot of chronic diseases and
these foods tend to be high in saturated
fat so it's not necessarily poisonous we
can tolerate a small amount of it the
American Heart Association says 5 to 6
percent of your calories from saturated
fat what does that mean that's about a
tablespoon of fat the high fat low carb
keto diet is gaining popularity as a
nutritionist what do you think of that
diet
well the ketogenic diet was first sort
of invented or developed many many years
ago for children with seizure disorders
and it was efficacious for these kids it
really helped them control their
seizures but for adults when you're
trying to lose weight it's not a great
idea it's not sustainable it's not
healthy over time you're going to regain
the weight you've lost and you've lost
the weight initially because its water
weight because you're limiting
carbohydrates quite severely it's a very
high fat diet lots and lots of fat
almost no carbohydrate at all mm-hmm
and the data is still clear what diet
works well and it depends on what you
mean what does works mean you know I
like people just to be healthy so we
like to look at dietary patterns like
the Mediterranean diet or a vegetarian
diet or the - diet more plant-based is
going to keep us healthier you don't
have to be a vegetarian but adding more
plants to your diet as a win-win
situation all right Samantha Heller more
plants thanks very much